Omega Mattel has announced that they're
working with Google on a new virtual
reality cardboard inspired reworking of
the original viewmaster the new virtual
reality device is based on Google's
virtual reality solution called
cardboard which actually was made out of
cardboard and a lot of assault with a
joke if you aren't understanding half
the words I'm saying here's a quick
rundown vivian master was a toy that you
for the card would circle of images into
and then look through to see
stereoscopic images which simulated 3d
cardboard with google super cheap
do-it-yourself vr alternative which
achieves the same result is holding up
your palms around your eyes to keep the
outside world out it uses what is
essentially a pair of glasses half a
shoebox and your phone to make an
improvised virtual reality headset this
new remaster will be a headset with a
slot for android smartphone which will
produce the images if you're thinking
this sounds childish it's because the
thing is aimed at kids and will be going
on the market for thirty dollars extra
real with new areas to explore will come
at 15 bucks a pop yes even Barbie doll
maker Mattel isn't safe from DLC fever
let me know if you've ever used a
viewmaster and what do you think of this
new one we'll be keeping you updated
with all the latest VR news both
cardboard and otherwise on gamespot